は)こんにちは！ドクターはじめと
よ)よっちでーす
[ｽﾞｷﾞｭﾝ(攻撃音)]　よ)ヲブス！！
は)というわけで、我々が今どこに来ているかというと
は)出身の富山県に来ております
よ)やったあーーー！
は)どうだ、よっち。何か思うことはないか
よ)人があんまりいないですね…
は)後、ほら見ろ
は&よ)シャッターだらけだ！
は)素直に表すと…
は)寂しい…！
は)というわけで、ここは魚津市なんですけど
は)我々富山県出身の者として、
よ)そうですね
は)この街を盛り上げるために何かできないかと考えたところ
は)魚津市さんの協力もいただいて、
は)この商店街のシャッターに
は)それを今回シャッターに　　　　　　　　　　　　描きまくっていこうと思います！
よ)はい！
は)まあ、ぱっと見落書きに見えるかもしれませんが…
よ)いや、そんなことない　そんなことない
は)では、挨拶に行きましょう！
♪移動
は&よ)あ、あ、あ、あ。 お、お、おお
は&よ)よろしくお願いしまーす
は)というわけで、手伝って下さる美術部の方々です
は&よ)よろしくお願いします 美)お願いします。
は)では、早速　作戦会議といきましょう
♪～
は)なに笑ってんだよ笑
♪移動
は)というわけで、作戦会議が終わりました！
は)美術部の人と連携して　　　　　　　　　　　　　もう描き始めてもらってます
は)まずは１枚目！描いていきましょう！
は)いきます！マジでいくぞ　うわやべえ怖え
は)魚津市の発展を祈って、描かせていただきます
よ)あーこれやばいわ　あっはこれやばいぞ絶対笑
よ)このシャッターの持ち主の人大丈夫かな
は)親に怒られるよ　ほんとに
は)いやまじで　よ)あっはは
よ)お母さんに怒られるよ　ほんとにこんな事したら
？)きゃー　は)見に来てる人がいますね
よ)ギャラリーがね
よ)いやもう、知ってる人はね　何を描いてるか分かってきたと思いますが
は)これ分かる人は分かると思う
は)やってみたくない？でも　よ)いやいや
は)やってみたくないですか？
よ)「はじめしゃちょー」とかならわかるよ
は)こんにちはー
は)僕の本名です
よ)どうですか？名前大丈夫ですか　これかいちゃって
よ)あはは　は)良かった　ありがとうございます
♪～
は)よしよし
♪移動
は)はい！というわけで、２枚目でございます
は)魚津市と言えば、　　　　　　　　　　　　　　　ホタルイカみたいなところがあるんで
は)この壁にたくさん描ければいいなと思います　　　よ)はい
よ)えー違うんかーい笑　は)あはは
♪～
♪移動
は)はい！というわけで、僕達が担当した部分はもう完成したんですけど
は&よ)うおおおお
は)トマトのヘタでございます
よ)すっごいー
は&よ)うわあーー
は)引き続きよろしくお願いします　よ)お願いします
は)次がですね、街の中心的な部分なんで　　　　　　結構いろんな人に見られる絵を見ていきましょう
は)さあ、どんなシャッターになっているんでしょうか！
は&よ)うわああああああ すっごい！
よ)うわーすごい！
は)あのこれ、よっちのメガネでございます
は)すごいね　良かったねー
は)うわっはは　すげー　よ)うわーすごい
よ)目立つわー
は&よ)うわ すごいわ
よ)これは…目立つわー
は)いやまじですごい…
は)本当にありがとうございます
よ)うわー嬉しいわー　は)いやすごい。まじですごい。
よ)いやこれすごいな　ここで見たときのインパクト感がすごい　は)ねっ
♪移動
は)はい！というわけで、もう日が暮れてきたので、　１日目終了でございます！
は)お疲れ様です　よ)お疲れ様です
は)まだね、完成してなかったり、1日目でできなかった部分とかあるんで、
は)もう　時間が許す限り、2日目もシャッターに　　　絵を描いていこうと思います
よ)はい
は)というわけで、よっちは
よ)なんでだよ　なんでだよ笑
は)予定があって、１日目で帰ってしまいます　　　　よ)すいません
は)ばいばいーうえーい　よ)軽いな
♪移動
は)はい！おはようございます　2日目でございます
は)というわけで、よっちがいなくなったんですけども
は)今日は1人＋美術部の方と頑張っていきたいと思います
は)で、残念ながらですね、天気がすごい悪いんですよ今日
は)ペンキ塗るのには、ちょっと大変なんですけど　　今日が最終日なんで頑張っていきたいと思います！
は)では行きましょう！！
は)はい、というわけで、まず最初の僕の仕事は
は)トマトのヘタの喋ってる部分を描こうと思います
♪作業中
は)はい、というわけで、ここは多分完成だと思います
は)トマトのヘタが魚津市に来てくれたあなたを【welcome！！】と歓迎しております
♪移動
は)はい、というわけで、次のシャッターでございます
は)こちらに、描いていこうと思います
は)あーもう取り戻しがつかないことになってしまい　ました
♪作業中
は)はあーー
は)出来ました！
は)ナスの妖怪でぃーす
は)分かります？この芸術的なポイント
は)ナスのお化けがバナナを持ちながら、イチゴと言っている…
は)この絵だけで、３種類の食べ物が連想されて、
♪作業中
は)オッケーです
♪移動
は)はい、というわけで、2日間かけて計８枚の　　　　シャッターアート…描き終わりましたー！
拍手👏
は)本当に、協力してくださって、　　　　　　　　　ありがとうございました！
は)はい、というわけで、もう全部完成したので、
は)早速シャッターアート見ていきましょう！
は)どうぞ！！
は)はい。というわけで、今回こんな感じで
は)シャッター街にシャッターアート描きまくるという企画を
は)日本財団さんとの取り組みでさせて頂きました
は)今起きてる問題を、放っておくと
は)もう、なおらないこともあるかもしれないので、
は)俺達とか、皆さんでやるしかないんですよ　　　　こういうことは！
は)ほんとにシャッター街とかも社会問題になってて
は)こういうもので、ちょっとでも変わればいいなと　思って僕、やったんですけど
は)ぜひ
は)皆さんも
は)この動画を見て、自分に出来る事があったらなって考えてくれるだけでも！嬉しいです
は)魚津に、シャッターアート見に来てくれるのは　　うれしいんだけど
は)俺のシャッターアートに…落書きすんなよ！